im tagesgespräch der frankfurter
virologe dr martin sturmer größe ganz
herzlich und hallo guten morgen
die ergebnisse des gipfels kennen wir
die frage ist impfen über 12 und in der
gegenwärtigen situation in der wir uns
befinden mit dem stoff lieferungen und
dergleichen ist das richtig aus ihrer
sicht oder nicht ganz richtig ja ich
glaube das thema ist aktuell ziemlich
emotional belastet und sehr schwierig
einzuordnen und interpretieren dass man
jetzt aus rein biologischer sicht jede
in kontakt für das virus den wir
wegnehmen durch impfung ist ein guter
eine eine gute aktion das heißt also aus
rein biologischer sicht plädiere ich
natürlich dafür auch die gruppe 12 bis
15 jährige zu impfen weil wir nehmen
einfach eine sehr mobile gruppe eine
probe mit vielen kontakten die auch viel
freizeitaktivität und und schulische
aktivität aufweist dass wir die aus der
gleichung rausnehmen für das virus eben
nicht mehr als infektionsherde nehmen
können aber eine priorisierung wie sie
zum beispiel der minister sparen
vorgeschlagen hatte sehen sie auch nicht
also eine notwendigkeit dafür
ja das ist ein ganz schwieriges thema
ich denke wir haben
priorisierung mit einer priorisierung
gestartet die ganz klar nach
krankheitssymptomen ausgerichtet war
also menschen die am meisten darunter
leiden zuerst zu impfen
ich bin immer noch der meinung wir
sollten das primär weiterhin tun es gibt
immer noch genug menschen die nicht
geimpft sind die es dringend regen
bräuchten
natürlich gibt es ganz viele menschen
die den impfstoff gerne haben möchten
und ich kann nachvollziehen dass auch
die zwölf- bis 15-jährigen jetzt gerne
weil sie so lange gewartet haben auch
vorgezogen werden aber ich halte davon
grundsätzlich nichts ich bin eher ein
freund davon wirklich jetzt weiterhin
sich auf die risikogruppen zu
konzentrieren und das was übrig bleibt
dann impfstoff dann eben entsprechend zu
verteilen das heißt dann auch bei
kindern dann mit vorerkrankungen
mit vorerkrankungen sind ja jetzt wieder
ein erhöhtes risiko wo man sagt da kann
er ein schwerer verlauf kommen ich denke
das ist auch wieder eine indikation wo
man sagt wenn der impfstoff entsprechend
zugelassen wenn der impfstoff
entsprechend sicher ist nach
einschätzung der fachleute die sich
damit permanent beschäftigen was ihm
stoffe angeht dann bin ich der meinung
dass man eben kindern mit
vorerkrankungen den stoff nicht
vorenthalten sollte sondern auch
prioritär insel sollte jetzt gibt es
natürlich die große klage nach zu wenig
impfstoffen die zur verfügung stehen es
werden auch noch weniger geliefert in
den nächsten wochen als angekündigt und
dazu kommt jetzt natürlich noch diese
dieser beschluss des gipfels und auch
noch dieser hinweis dass man ja
vielleicht dann doch auch zum beispiel
vakzine mischen kann miteinander nach
astrazeneca dann moderner zu geben oder
bei und advisor würden sie so eine
mischung von impfstoffen tatsächlich
befürworten
ja es ist auch eine sehr schwierige
frage es gibt jetzt eine studie die
zeigt oder zeigen soll wie wirksam und
wie gut das ganze ist wir haben bis dato
gesehen dass es funktioniert
es ist einfach ein problem das wir im
augenblick immer noch mängel verwalten
und so lange man mängel verwaltet muss
man halt schauen wie man da eine gewisse
struktur rein bekommt und ich gebe ihnen
recht ich sehe die struktur aktuell
nicht wirklich es wird konkret und quer
geimpftes wird über kreuz kämpft und
damit verlieren wir so ein bisschen den
überblick und ich denke trotzdem dass es
die realität sein wird dass wir halt
eben einfach um die geschwindigkeit
aufrecht zu halten möglichst schnell
möglichst viele menschen zu impfen
halt eben auch manche maßnahmen treffen
müssen und dazu wird das überkreuzen
dazu wo wir noch keine wirklich guten
wissenschaftlichen belege haben geht
ihnen die immunisierung der bevölkerung
in deutschland eigentlich schnell genug
es ist eine ganz schwierige lage sagt
zum beispiel kollege drosten eine der
schwierigsten phasen überhaupt natürlich
mit dem fingerzeig auf die politik dies
alles irgendwie regeln muss wo stehen
wir derzeit in der pandemie wenn ich mir
den pandemie verlauf angucke haben wir
die chance zumindest für deutschland
mehr oder weniger auf die zielgerade
eingebogen zu sein
wir sehen sinkende fallzahlen wer
geben gas mit dem impfen klar könnte das
schneller gehen aber wir wissen alle
dass lieferschwierigkeiten nicht in
unserer hand stecken und wir können uns
natürlich immer noch selber ein bein
stellen aber wenn alles gut läuft denke
ich schon dass wir richtung herbst mehr
oder weniger ein trend aus der pandemie
rausgekommen können und da wird das in
von ganz wichtig bleiben und mit unser
wichtigster baustein sein und deswegen
hoffe ich auch dass es weiter schnell
voran geht und dass diese
lieferschwierigkeiten wirklich schnell
behoben werden und wir ausreichend
impfstoff haben und dann kommen diese
nachrichten aus großbritannien dass die
zahlen der infektionen wieder steigen
die sind ja nun relativ weit mit dem
impfen und es gab bisher ja in den
letzten wochen wirklich gute zahlen von
dort gute nachrichten die indischen
mutation macht sich dort breit haben sie
dafür sorge dass es hier genauso
passiert ja das ist natürlich eine sorge
die ich denke meine kollegen und ich
alle haben dass wir das virus
unterschätzen dass wir jetzt diese
fallenden zahlen und die wärmere
jahreszeit dahingehend interpretieren
dass die pandemie mehr oder weniger
vorbei ist aber das ist sie nicht das
virus ist weiterhin noch unter uns dass
infizieren sich immer noch menschen mit
dem virus und wir geben damit eben auch
varianten die chance sich bei kämpfen
durchzusetzen und dementsprechend müssen
wir weiter vorsichtig sein
wir müssen die kontakte auf ein minimum
beschränken um eben nicht die entweder
die indische variante oder eben auch die
neue variante zum vorschein kommen zu
lassen sie sich dann wieder ausbreiten
kann also da habe ich schon ein bisschen
sorgen hätten wir mal ganz kurz über die
englische variante was ist ihre
erfahrung wie verbreitet oder wie auch
im ansteigen ist diese infektion also
ich sehe sie im augenblick auf einen
mehr oder weniger konstanten level
niedrigen level so zwischen zwei
zweieinhalb prozent anteil an den
typisierten proben in unserer datenbank
quasi zwei wochen gar nicht zu finden
jetzt haben wir sie wieder in ungefähr 2
200 prozent der fälle gesehen
also ich sehe da noch keinen
signifikanten anstieg dieser variante
aber es ist natürlich immer das
potenzial da wenn dann mal so ein
größerer ausbruch durch diese variante
ausgelöst wird dass dann möglicherweise
ein schneeball effekt eintritt und sich
die variante ausbreiten kann aber
aktuell vom jetzigen stand
ist die b 11 7 also die sogenannte
britische variante die haupt variante
während die indische variante da ein
bisschen mut auf einem niedrigen niveau
wir reden wir zum schluss noch über die
perspektiven die sie sehen und wo sie
sagen das müssen wir tun damit will gute
perspektiven haben lockerungen weiterhin
wie sieht's aus mit sport mit kultur und
der warmen jahreszeit ihr uns jetzt
vielleicht ins haus steht
also alles was sie zum außenbereich
stattfindet bin ich relativ entspannt so
lange sich nicht zu viele menschen
zusammenballen
weil dann wird es auch im freien gehen
sich anzustecken gerade im kontext von
varianten die sich deutlich effektiver
verbreiten alles was im innenraum
stattfindet da würde ich jetzt weiterhin
noch für zurückhaltung plädieren also
öffnung der in gastronomie und so weit
käme für mich jetzt noch nicht in frage
ähnliches gilt eben für kulturelle
veranstaltungen im inneren
da würde ich warten bis die zahlen noch
weiter deutlich nach unten gegangen sind
und wir mehr geimpft haben rein
perspektivisch denke ich dass der
übergang vom sommer in den herbst
entscheidend wird inwieweit sich das
virus zurückziehen oder wir es geschafft
haben das virus zurück zu drängen sich
keine neue varianten gebildet haben
möglicherweise bekommen wir wieder einen
leichten anstieg aber keine vierte welle
das wäre wenn es alles optimal läuft
meine prognose für den herbst da freuen
wir uns wenn die prognose eintrifft
dankeschön dr martin sturmer danke schon
in frankfurt sehr gerne